my name is Jeff herd and I'm working as  the strength conditioning coach to help  Jamarcus with his comeback when we first  started honestly you could tell that the  athletic gifts were there but Jamarcus  you know I've been not active his  strength levels were down his body  weight was up where we're at today  compared to you know day one is miles of  difference and Durin's getting better  know everything just that much better  you know when things are going the right  way and the way they should though there  should be my experience would be right  now they'd say you know what we got to  take a serious look at this guy I'd be  surprised if he's not at somebody's can